gwen stefani and blake shelton are on
their honeymoon and it's anything but
conventional this will be documented in
history forever
on wednesday the 51 year old singer
shared some pics and videos on instagram
from her husband's performance at bash
on the bay a country music festival in
puddin bay ohio
[Music]
gwen shared selfies from backstage and
the concert setlist which included her
two duets with blake happy anywhere
[Music]
and she used the song titles to caption
her post writing quote
honeymoon tour with my blake shelton
ohio hashtag happy anywhere
nobody but you
i think i'm his biggest fan gwen also
shared a few moments from the night on
her insta story
that was me touching your belly but
including a couple selfies of her outfit
their pup a pic of her hubby on the bus
her after show look the moment blake
lost his wallet their police escort
with their dog of course and a ride in a
boat
but the ohio show wasn't the first time
they performed together since tying the
knot in july blake and gwen shared the
stage at the country crooner's old red
bar in his native oklahoma and again the
two saying happy anywhere and nobody but
you
yeah stephanie is singing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nobody but you are in the two a cmt
award earlier this year and another nom
for an academy of country music award
something blake reflected on during a
chat with e.t
i texted her actually
this morning on the way here i wish she
was here with me and i said i can't
believe that
i get to be nominated for awards with my
best friend you know and it was just one
of those moments it's like how do you
get
so blessed and so lucky you know the two
tied the knot back in july at blake's
oklahoma ranch and the wedding was
officiated by the voice host carson daly
it's one of those once in a lifetime
you know moments a source at the time
told e.t that the intimate nuptials were
a quote fairytale experience even for
the guests quote everyone who attended
the ceremony was talking about gwen and
blake's love for one another they have
both been through a lot and deserve to
find each other they were meant to be a
couple in every way
[Music]